[Gelächter]
hallo mein name ist luca und ich würde
der wechsel youtuber der welt vermisst
euch ja so ist herzlich willkommen wir
heute zu einem neuen video meine damen
und herren und zwar habe ich hier schon
sechs kleine zettelchen vorbereitet und
einen edding erste denn in elbing
vorbereitet den spielen heute wer bin
ich das habe ich schon im titel gewesen
wenn nicht dann könnt ihr nicht lesen
ich werde jetzt auf jeden fall einen
youtuber hier auf dem zettel schreiben
und den max an die stirn kleben max mit
einem fetten aufschreiben und wird für
mich und wir müssen dann immer den
youtuber raten der quasi auf unserer
stirn steht und die anderen müssen die
frage beantworten mit ja oder nein als
frage mit ja beantwortet wird darf ich
eine zweite frage stellen und falls wir
mit nein beantwortet werden max dann
quasi in der reihe also immer an dem
durchlaufen
ja wir fangen an
man darf nur ja oder nein fragen stehen
und man hat nur zwei euro fragen stellen
das ist eine regel die kräfte dieser
kleber es los wenn ich ja allein auf
einem kanal deutschen videos absolut und
das steht ja gewohnt in deutschland ja
es ist deutschland frank 5000 euro
er wurde in nrw nein mach ich deutsche
videos jaja lebe ich heute auch in
deutschland ja okay dann war's okay
machen
40 das mal videos über mädchen okay bin
ich ein
jetzt bin ich ein fremdsprachiger kanal
sprechen meinen videos englisch
da bin ich eine person er wurde ich in
den vereinigten staaten von amerika ich
glaube ja mache ich komme die videos
obwohl ich im norden deutschlands air
hamburg reeperbahn polizist fragen kann
richtig nein nein nein nein nein sagen
okay darf ich ja hier komme ich will
sich ausblick siehst du kannst doch
nicht deutschen ja in der tat
[Musik]
nein und ich wie das zu populären themen
die meist so zu aktuellen eigentlich
nicht die vielen immer so ein populäres
thema sagst du jetzt eher so was gerade
so ein trend sachen so die finder oder
so ein jahr oder bayerisches binner dann
kann der planung dann ja schon in einer
gewissen form das sollte jetzt nichts
kerstin service ist noch ein junger
zweig republik wie honig in
niedersachsen
na ja wieder menschen von der sachsen 3
2 mussten aber aus hessen ich wohne in
deutschland richtig egal wie oft auch ja
ok habe ich über eine million abonnenten
nein was habe ich über 1 millionen
abonnenten
das war zu viel habe ich über fünf
millionen aber nicht das waren die
beiden aber fragen danach wie viel
michael bublé nämlich republik wirklich
weit geprüft wird ob steht mache ich
blogs es kann sein dass schon mal ein
blog gemacht hat sich auf einem anderen
kanal oder keine ahnung was aber den
kanal geradesteht nicht komme aus
niedersachsen
nein
ein männlicher youtuber deutscher der
deutsche videos macht aus niedersachsen
und ich bin nicht mal täler black ich
wäre dann schmeckt ich würde euch zu
hoffen dass ich jetzt so gesund so wird
ihr wann kommt er so ein rostocker
services in rostock habe ich mal gaming
videos gemacht hat beim kanalbau ich
glaub man habe ich unter einer million
aber den ball nicht über eigene
millionen mache ich gaming videos nein
nein leider habe ich jemals jahre mache
ich nein seit über fünf jahren
ja ja kann ich so sagen ja was du tust
du dir das an alter mann gerne
challenges nee ich will sagen mein
geständnis kein blog was kann man denn
sonst noch machen keine ahnung alters
und blogs ok wohne ich auf einem
übergriff jahre bin ich für uns immer
noch und zwar ganz kurz zusammenzufassen
ich habe unter eine million abonnenten
dann kommen aus deutschland machen keine
comedy videos material keine gaming
video hier mache ich so kommen die
unterhaltung videos nein das mache ich
gerne videos ja habe ich mein kreft
gespielt er mache ich noch aktiv
minecraft videos ja bin ich sogar dass
minecraft habe ich über eine million
er verfügt genau das mache ich
content in dem ich mich so viel auf das
aktuelle geschehen auf youtube
auch über andere leute meine meinung
sage ich auch schon kräftig getreten
habe ich so eine news kanal bin ich
männlich ist nicht weniger ehrlich ja
okay das weiß ich bescheid wohne ich in
köln nicht im ernst ich bin ich kämpfen
zwar wir sind die einzige kraft kennst
ihn so sale sowie jeden einen tipp
daneben gehen ich will apple den tipp
geben ist ein urgestein auf youtube bis
2 kanal
ich will dich so hart zu den kopf
gestellt ist schon mal nicht schlecht
aber in front seit nicht einmal einen
grund in anderson
russland ist ein ort rilax beschreibt
mixa bot in köln kommt macht zumal ich
konnte es nicht
es habe ich sie marie ist es nicht sagt
das nicht können wir erst wenn dies
nicht möglich ist habe ich über zwei
millionen hat es schon zwei jahre steht
neben dem knopf die man die komponenten
denn es ist die größte als zwei
millionen franken
bild bernd bunte haare wenig 12 kanal
bin ich ein zweiter kanal von einem
youtuber der über eine million
abonnenten hat es ist wirklich so dass
ich nicht in köln wo das gab daraufhin
gesagt wichtig ich wohne nicht in köln
wurde nicht in köln und ich bin ein
zweiter kanal wäre noch machen kann dann
blogs hochgeladen oder in richtung ich
denke gerade am pool ihren job weil er
kommt aus köln fuhr davon
1 comment mit dem b an bin ich denn da
die leds du kannst auch du da ist
minecraft zu beginn hätte das
schwierigste und hat als erster sein
mandant habe bitte nachschauen wie
youtube stand ist ja was weiß ich denn
mir fällt jetzt kein jockel ein es sein
kann
ihr habt gesagt ich äußere mich auf mein
zimmer videos zu arten geschehen etwas
passiert was auf youtube passiert ja
danke übrig zu 2,8 millionen ist die
besten hashtag lucio baudenkmal nach ja
was der youtube buch schreibst du der
optimale termin würden sowas wollen
vielmehr bestandteilen der außenseiter
möglichkeiten schlug abwählen damit nur
noch wenig der zweite kanal von dem der
hauptkanal zeitlich ist nein noch ein
tipp ja gema beste nach unten
deutschland station in sceaux bleibst da
ja
da ist einmal die penaltys und wilfried
check and channel auf das ist hier von
meine damen und herren wir haben
aufgepasst jetzt kann man auf max kanal
und wir auch noch videos aufgenommen
mein max kommt das wahrscheinlich dann
drei monaten online archiv video
gefallen hat das ja nun mal einen like
da und sonst würde ich sagen schreib mir
in die kommentare
wer warum schreibt ihr wer aber macht
trotzdem macht man hat diese gute frage
und die anderen sollen antworten ja oder
nein
aber alles was ihr vom video das war es
jetzt hier vom video hier können jetzt
jemanden kanal abonnieren oder hier
unten meinen job aus checken jetzt
findet ihr zwei andere videos und wenn
ihr schon abonnent seid könnt ihr auf
die glocke klicken dann willkommen die
benachrichtigungen
[Musik]